das hier ist das erste produkt sofern
man ins hauptfeld produkt nennen kann
das ich jemals testen
zudem ist kein original gibt hey was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu und
ein video habe ich hoffe natürlich jedes
gut
web to date und zwar ein neues kleines
unboxing-video ich freue mich die teile
liegen hier schon lange rum alter warte
man hier sind um dieses paket sollte wir
können uns eigentlich schon direkt
einsetzen
ich stehe hier sowie falschgeld ihr
könnt euch auch in zukunft wieder auf
ganz viele neue an boxen videos freuen
lustige unboxing videos wie ist ja schon
stau auf dem tisch solange wir den nicht
mehr benutzt alter heute haben wir ein
produkt hast du übrigens gesehen dass
unsere nachbarländer sohn hans schild
dran gehangen hat mir lieber zurück so
schild anhängers leere
[Gelächter]
dieses produkt heute das ist ein das ist
genial
das ist nämlich ein produkt ich dachte
hey bin ich blöd wieso finde ich dazu
keine original bewegungs meine haare
wurden gleich frisiert minister nicht
mitbekommen haben jetzt zum ersten mal
sehr wundert euch nicht erklären was das
video ab dazu weil er sich in der
beschreibung das hier ist das erste
produkt sofern man ins hauptfeld produkt
nennen kann das ich jemals tester zudem
es kein original gibt ja zu diesem
produkt gibt es kein originales produkt
das ist ja schon das next level oder wie
sie ist dann überhaupt fällt weiß ich
nicht aber die masse tobt ich hab das
mal auf wird es mal aus ich habe es
natürlich schon gesehen also weil es ja
immer alles zugeordnet wie zwar kennt ja
jeder dieser beats kopfhörer sehr
bekannte marke an sich war es auch gut
eingepackt ganz kurz leute damit ihr das
einmal seht um diese dinger geht es hier
haben mich 15 euro kostet 8 euro
standardversand also insgesamt 23 ich
habe die in weiß ausgewählt habt ihr
schon gesehen also ich finde ich oft
meinen bildern sieht absolut nice aus
auch sehr hochwertig die haben auch eine
gute bewertung finde ich also 4,1 stern
ich habe die auch schon mit 4,5 sternen
gesehen da gibt es ja mal mehrere
anbieter und die können eigentlich das
was alle anderen billig bluetooth
reports auch können steht jetzt muss ich
glaube ich nicht alles einmal vorlesen
ja ich bin jetzt einfach mal gespannt
lieferung schneller als erwartet sabine
da hast du glück gehabt also bei mir das
recht lange gedauert
naja vielleicht geht es wieder schneller
also leute weiter geht's
jetzt haben wir auch mal leute es hat
wirklich ewig gedauert bis diese dinge
angekommen sind ich habe die sich vor
zwei monaten bestellt und wir sind jetzt
letzte woche eingeführt hat liegt halt
an den ganzen corona krank und so also
ich hab mir das produkt genau angeschaut
beatz hat keine bluetooth reports also
die originale beats marke bietet das
nicht an und hat sie irgendeinen
chinesischer store gedacht schlecht für
die gut für uns denn des bizerba
biotherapies pott export hier steht es
noch mal darauf wie zwei dr dre
dieses logo gemacht also ist es erkennt
an dem logo des fake ist an der
schriftart das normale beats das ist
normal rot und lila und die
schriftleitung zeit absolut scheiße hier
können wären abstrich suchen wenn ihr
irgendwann original dazu findet schickt
sie mir ich hab es nicht gefunden
deswegen bin ich jetzt mal gespannt was
auf mich zukommt aber erste eindruck ist
schon mal nicht schlecht machen wir die
mal auf guck mal
also ich glaube wir hatten noch kein
paket in dem so ihr platz drin waren was
auf den ersten eindruck hochwertiger
gewirkt hat oder nochmal hier schön mit
der vergoldung 23 euro da kann man nicht
mehr kann ok das ist das case sagt leute
schaut nur auf das case und wichtig
motiviert so und hier kurz ar games für
zwischendurch und hier
hier haben wir jetzt ein oranges mini
usb kabel also da hat sich jemand
wirklich was gedacht beim design auch
nicht schlecht hier haben wir dann noch
diese tropfen und naja hier die
kopfhörer feiere ich eigentlich also
erinnern ein bisschen an
airports pro vielleicht ein ich bin hier
wirklich vom design beeindruckt
das sind an sich die schönsten ihr platz
die ich je gesehen habe also fürs
aussehen würden die auf jeden fall zehn
punkte kriegen aber es geht ja sicher um
den kern genau die habe ich jetzt mal
kurz airports um die dann eben zu dem
gemacht da sieht man schon leichte
übereinstimmung
ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt so das
case kann man aufklappen und dann legen
wir die einfach mal so da rein glaube
schon und haben stets wie du dein ding
irgendwas funktioniert hier nicht ganz
so wisse ja dass ihr habe ich zu jetzt
laden wir auch ihr könnt sehr gerne eure
meinung dazu in die kommentare schreiben
auch nicht dieses wir haben ja gar nicht
dieses billige rot blau blinkenden wir
es ja sonst kennen und jetzt muss ich
sagen ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was
sie können
ich habe es ja schon gesagt haben 23
euro kostet 15 euro das produkt plus
acht weitere euro versand keine ahnung
warum der versand so teuer war aber gut
dann machen wir uns mal einen soundcheck
das ja auch das wichtigste ich bin
extrem gespannt was sie können
vielleicht haben wir hier so ein kleines
schätzchen ein weg vorbei wenn man damit
rumläuft leute die sich auskennen
ich denke ich ja dann hoch oder alter
neues schild den lehrer hat goldene
beats leuten ist das kenne ich ja noch
gar nicht deswegen naja mal schauen was
ich auch ganz gut im ohr
was würdest du sagen die das gut aus sie
stehen so ein bisschen abhalten so wo
siehst du aus wie ein
call-center-mitarbeiter usa schon gut
tut und ein sehr angenehmes tut fans die
leute die diese zahlen dass ich wichtig
im winter sei okay warten jetzt mal ab
hier sind sie schon da habe ich jetzt
einfach mal gebrochen dass man die so
verbindet man muss die anderen sorten
und dann kann man hier l2 willen und
jetzt habe ich gerade auf dem ort schon
gehört connected wir schauen mal eine
unbedingt kann man die nicht
aber gut ich bin so gespannt finde mal
richtig nervös sitzt davor ok komme ich
ja mal was von dir play off the future
[Musik]
ach jetzt habe ich gerade entdeckt wir
haben auf beiden seiten noch so tasten
hier kümmern
mit dem man dann die liederauswahl
steuern kann das bei den großen beats
auch so ja ja die haben auch so richtig
große tasten auch ganz einfach das
system drückt man einmal macht pause
drückt man zweimal mit der nächste song
abgespielt ok
[Musik]
schade alter also ich habe wirklich
gehofft dass sie sich dass das gut
klingt aber es klingt halt nicht gut
es klingt wieder ein bisschen nach
plastik da ist nicht viel drin in diesen
dingern pass fehlt extrem das ist so
schade da wäre ich jetzt mitarbeiter der
originalen beats firma nenne ich jetzt
mal so und dieses fred produkt sehen
würde
ohne scheiß ich gehört dass in gute
nachricht was heißt gut dann macht das
muss man sich mal geben
dann macht das original oder ist
eigentlich unternehmen den fake nach nur
halten besser weil leute ich ohne scheiß
das design von den dingern
ich finde das sieht so hammer aus das
kann man vielleicht noch natürlich wenn
man die jetzt so in der hand hat man
merkt dass da ein bisschen die qualität
wird aber wenn man das ein guter
qualität produziert mit leisen klang
irgendwelchen anderen features
meinetwegen auch die verpackung auf geil
macht es einfach eins zu eins nach es
wird ein absoluter erfolg würde ich mal
sagen also die fake sind vom sound her
absolut scheiße ich weiß nicht wir
können natürlich jetzt hier auch noch
eine mikrofonen checkt machen oder
sonstiges nur eben wie aus dem alter bin
ich raus
ja also ich bin leider ein bisschen
enttäuscht vom sound da hab ich mir was
besseres erhofft aussehen zehn von zehn
bis jetzt geilsten die wir je hatten
nur ich kann euch die leute trotzdem
nicht unbedingt ans herz legen klar für
23 euro ist das gesamte package in
ordnung nur wir hatten leider schon das
ein oder andere bessere produkt vom
klang her auf jeden fall sollte trotzdem
verlor sich diese dinger wie immer auch
am instagram ihr müsst ihr einfach meine
story antworten alex wie genau
trotzdem bin ich mal auf eure meinung
zum design in den kommentaren gespannt
und ich würde sagen so viel dazu
abonniert auf jeden fall mein zweiter
kanal
da kommt jeden tag um 9 uhr 30 morgens
schon ein video mit ganz oben die
beschreibung verlinkt würde ich mich
sehr freuen
und wir sehen uns dann hier übermorgen
wahrscheinlich wieder gibt's neues video
und meinst du ja immer instagram alex
wie dank fürs zuschauen aber nicht den
kanal 32